first-year students at a certain large
university are required to live on
campus in one of the 24 available
residence halls after their first year
students have the option to live away
from campus but many choose to continue
living in the residence halls Estella
oversees 12 of these residence halls her
department surveyed a large simple
random sample of first-year students who
live in those 12 residence halls about
their overall satisfaction with campus
living Estella can safely generalize the
results of the survey to which
population so pause this video and see
if you could figure it out alright so
let's do this together so Estella has
done it's a large simple random sample
of first-year students so let's see
choice a is only those students who were
surveyed well no this was a this was a
simple random sample and it was a large
sample so it's meant to be indicative of
all first-year students you can
generalize more than just making
statements about just the students who
are surveyed all first-year students but
only those who live in these 12
residence halls yeah I think this one
looks fair because you can't generalize
to people who don't live in those
residence halls maybe Estella
oversees the 12 best residence halls or
the 12 worst residence halls and so you
wouldn't get if that were the case you
would not be able to generalize beyond
that or these might be the 12 that are
closest to campus or the 12 that are
furthest from campus so you can only
generalize to people who live in those
residence halls all students first year
not but only those who live in these 12
residence halls
well the issue here is is that a 2nd
year student or 3rd year student might
just have a different perspective even
if they live in those in that same
building and we did a large random
sample of first year students we didn't
do a large random sample of all people
in that in that those 12 residence halls
so rule that out all first year students
at the entire university but not
students
beyond their first year well this
wouldn't make sense because there would
be first-year students who would be
outside of those residence halls and as
I already mentioned the ones that
Estella manages might not be indicative
of where all of the first-year students
in this university live